All right, everyone come on in, gather in, gather in, if you can hear my voice, turn
around.
And we are about to begin.
Welcome to the table 2026 Palm Sunday.
Yes, it's a special one, all right, so if you're, if this is your first time to be here
with us on Palm Sunday, well, you're in for a treat, my friends, because this is the day
that we commemorate and remember Christ to enter Jerusalem riding on donkey, and of course
the people all were shouting, Hosanna, and praise God, and they had the palm fronds and
laid it out before him and all that.
So we're going to kind of reenact that, in a moment I'll have a kind of read response
from Psalm 118, but what we'll do is after that read, I'll lead us into the sanctuary,
and we'll take at least, we'll do two laps, all right, we got to go, we got to play it
up and we have to do, I mean, it doesn't work if you don't engage it, you got to like, it's
like theater or something, right?
Some of you theater people, you got to like, lead us out of this, okay, so you got to shout
out, you know, praise the Lord, hallelujah, Hosanna, it's like classic Palm Sunday language
stuff.
All right, so you got it, everyone following me, you're, you're in, okay, we're in, children
will always be good.
All right, so this is a read response from Psalm 118, so I'm going to read a line, and
then you're going to respond with the phrase, His love endures forever, same line over and
over, okay?
So give thanks to the Lord, for He is good, His love endures forever.
Let the people of God say, His love endures forever.
I will give you thanks for you answered me, His love endures forever.
The stone that the builders rejected has become the cornerstone, His love endures forever.
Let us rejoice today and be glad, His love endures forever.
The Lord has made His light to shine on us, His love endures forever.
With palms in hand, join in the festal procession, His love endures forever.
Give thanks to the Lord, for He is good, His love endures forever.
Rosanna, Rosanna, you are the God who saves us, worthy of all our praises.
Rosanna, Rosanna, come have your way among us, we welcome you here, Lord Jesus.
Praise is rising, eyes are turning to you, we turn to you.
Hope is stirring, hearts are yearning for you, and I'm for you.
Cause when we see you, we find strength to face the day.
In your presence, all our fears are washed away, are washed away.
Rosanna, Rosanna, you are the God who saves us, worthy of all our praises.
Rosanna, Rosanna, come have your way among us, we welcome you here, Lord Jesus.
Hear the sound of hearts returning to you, we turn to you.
In your kingdom, broken lives are made new, you make us new.
And when we see you, we find strength to face the day.
In your presence, all our fears are washed away, are washed away.
Rosanna, Rosanna, you are the God who saves us, worthy of all our praises.
Rosanna, Rosanna, come have your way among us, we welcome you here, Lord Jesus.
I just want to give a big shout out to you introverts who are just about to die in that entire exercise.
Way to go! You made it through.
Our kids are dismissed to go to their kids ministry classes. You can meet your teachers over by the doors.
Thank you so much, kids ministry team, for loving on these guys and showing them the love of God.
Bye, Virgo!
Alright, should I roll with the normal prayers of the people?
Okay.
Alright, we are going to transition now into the prayers of the people.
So if you guys have been here before, you know, follow along on the screens.
The parts that are in red, we will read aloud together.
And are you guys able to put that up on? Thank you. Great.
Alrighty.
Jesus, for this city of Sachse, Texas and for every city and community and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth you have given us and the wisdom and the will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and orphan, for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute, for prisoners and captives and all who remember and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized, and those unjustly targeted for their gender, sexuality, race, or other perceived difference, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection, and for those struggling with mental and emotional health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that you hear us, so we lift these names and situations up to you.
Johnny Owen.
Katelyn.
Jennifer.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we have kept in our hearts, we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope, peace, and a deep sense of your presence. Amen.
Worthy of every song we could ever sing, worthy of all the praise we could ever bring,
worthy of every breath we could ever breathe, we live for you.
Jesus, the name above every other name, Jesus, the only one who could ever say,
worthy of every breath you could ever breathe, we live for you. We live for you.
And holy, there is no one like you, there is none beside you.
Open up my eyes in wonder and show me who you are and fill me with your heart and lead me in your love to those around me.
Jesus, the name above every other name, Jesus, the only one who could ever say,
worthy of every breath we could ever breathe, we live for you. We live for you.
And holy, there is no one like you, there is none beside you.
Open up my eyes in wonder and show me who you are and fill me with your heart and lead me in your love to those around me.
I will build my life upon your love, it is the first foundation.
I will put my trust in you alone and I will not be shaken.
And holy, there is no one like you, there is none beside you.
Open up my eyes in wonder and show me who you are and fill me with your heart and lead me in your love to those around me.
And I just want to sit here at your feet, I'm caught up in this holy moment, I never want to leave.
Oh I'm not here for blessings, Jesus you don't owe me anything, more than anything that you can do and I just want you.
And I'm sorry when I've just gone through the motions, I'm sorry when I just sang another song, take me back to where we started, I open up my heart to you.
And I'm sorry when I've come with my agenda, I'm sorry when I forgot that you're enough, take me back to where we started, I open up my heart to you.
And I'm caught up in your presence, I just want to sit here at your feet, I'm caught up in this holy moment, I never want to leave.
Oh I'm not here for blessings, Jesus you don't owe me anything, more than anything that you can do and I just want you.
And I just want you and nothing else, and nothing else, and nothing else will do.
I just want you and nothing else, and nothing else, and nothing else will do.
I just want you and nothing else, and nothing else, Jesus, nothing else will do.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
And I'm caught up in your presence.
And I just want to sit here at your feet.
I'm caught up in this holy moment.
I never want to leave.
No, I'm not here for blessings.
Jesus, you don't owe me anything.
More than anything that you can do, I just want you.
And I will build my life upon your love.
It is a firm foundation.
I will put my trust in you alone.
And I will not be shaken.
I will build my life upon your love.
It is a firm foundation.
I will put my trust in you alone.
And I will not be shaken.
And holy, there is no one like you.
There is none beside you.
Open up my eyes in wonder.
And show me who you are.
And fill me with your heart.
And lead me in your love to those around me.
And holy, there is no one like you.
There is none beside you.
Open up my eyes in wonder.
And show me who you are.
And fill me with your heart.
And lead me in your love to those around me.
God, would you continue to lead us?
And would we be brave enough, would we be courageous enough to let you lead?
To open our grasp of control?
To let go of some of our fear?
Our anxiety?
Our performance?
Our reputations?
God, the things that trip us up and keep us so centered on ourselves.
God, would you help our hands to loosen up the grip so that you can lead us into a life of love?
God, in those holy moments that we long for, would you help us to find them?
When we're sitting at dinner with our friends or our family.
When we're engaging in conversations with the people at work.
God, when we're raising our kids or out in nature.
God, would you show us the holy moments where you come to meet us in your grace.
In your goodness.
Even amidst our stress.
Our manipulation.
Our struggles.
God, even there, would we find you breaking through?
Would we invite you into those moments?
Open our eyes, open our hearts to more of your love.
To more of your ways.
And would we be better? Would our lives and our families, our friendships, our world be a better place because of it?
Would it be warmer and more welcoming?
Would our invitation extend to everyone, just as yours has, God?
We love you and we need you.
And we celebrate you and the good work that you did so that we could have a life full of love.
Full of hope and forgiveness.
In Jesus' name.
Amen.
Thank you guys.
Would you all turn to the person on your right and left and say,
The peace of Christ be with you.
And then Brett will start on our message.
Grace and peace.
My name is Brett and I'm the pastor here.
And yeah, it's a joy.
A joy to be with you in this space, to welcome all of you.
And that, as always, includes those joining us online.
Love you all lots.
And especially anyone here tonight who is new.
Thanks for having the courage to come into a new space.
I know that can be challenging.
And you joined us on a weird Sunday, too.
That intro.
For anyone who missed it, you don't know what I'm talking about.
If you were here earlier, then you know.
And yeah, we're just glad that you could be with us on this special Palm Sunday.
Before we kind of jump into some details,
I want to mention you might notice there's like a little index card there,
sort of like every other seat, I think, with a pin.
And those are specifically for you to be able to write in a kind of nomination
for a special Sunday Unbound service we have coming up in May
where we're going to go out into the community
and do some service project kind of stuff.
So we're just really honestly trying to show up for people and be there for them.
So it's less of like going to like an institution,
and it's more of like the idea is maybe probably a home,
where someone might need a meal cooked.
Maybe cook it here in the church kitchen and take it there
or at someone's house and take it to their home.
Or maybe someone needs their home cleaned or lawn mowed
or some practical thing fixed or whatever.
So we're looking kind of for some nominations
so we can have a number of things that people can do in that slot in May.
So at any rate, if you could fill that out,
and then there's that little wooden box over there on the credence,
and you can just drop it in there.
Yes, Gary.
Yes, and you can nominate yourself.
If there's something like really big, you're like,
oh my gosh, this is like a huge, this could be really helpful.
It's okay.
We can help folks in our community as well.
So that's allowed.
It's allowed.
So at any rate, yeah, just to know that is perfectly okay.
All right.
So as you know today, well, fairly obviously,
is Palm Sunday and commemorates the arrival of Christ in Jerusalem,
the place where he would eventually be crucified and resurrected.
And, you know, the last few years,
maybe even since the beginning of the table,
I've done very like Palm Sunday sermons on Palm Sunday, and it makes sense.
But this year I'm going to do something a little bit different,
and we're going to do, it's known as Passion Sunday,
where you kind of start with Palm Sunday,
but then you kind of start to turn towards the cross.
And I want to do that partly because I know not everyone's able to make
the Good Friday service.
That'll be here at 7 o'clock on Friday,
where we're going to join in with Sachse first for their service.
And, you know, I know like work schedules and various things.
Not everyone's able to.
So there's something a little bit strange about kind of going from like the,
you know, Hosanna of Palm Sunday to the He is risen of Easter,
you know, without kind of like taking at least a little time to kind of
meditate and reflect on,
on the cross of Jesus and all the events surrounding that.
And so that's what we're going to be kind of doing tonight.
So with that in mind, the title of my message,
this Passion Palm Sunday is the crowd, the crowd.
And our primary scripture is Isaiah chapter 50, verses six through nine.
It's a prophetic text.
It was written actually many hundreds of years before Christ,
but Christian thinkers couldn't really help but see almost a foreshadowing of
what Christ would go through, you know, in this chapter.
I mean, it's quite uncanny, the description that Isaiah the prophet gave.
And so that reads starting in verse six, it says,
I gave my back to those who struck me and my cheeks to those who pulled out the beard.
I did not hide my face from insult and spitting.
The Lord God helps me.
Therefore, I have not been disgraced.
Therefore, I have set my face like flint and I know that I shall not be put to shame.
He who vindicates me is near.
Who will contend with me?
Let us stand in court together.
Who are my adversaries?
Let them confront me.
It is the Lord God who helps me.
Who will declare me guilty?
All of them will wear out like a garment.
The moth will eat them up.
So as the title of my message indicates,
I want to focus on and kind of reflect on the role, the place of the crowd.
And really kind of during Holy Week.
Because the crowd is present there on Palm Sunday as we all just enacted.
You are the crowd.
And, of course, the crowd is there on Good Friday as well.
So they kind of shout, you know, praise him and hallelujah there on Palm Sunday.
And then kind of revile and insult him on Good Friday.
And you can pick up on the role of the crowd in this passage as we just read.
Verse 6, I gave my back to those who struck me.
This isn't like an individual.
It's like this group of people.
Who are my adversaries?
Let them confront me.
Verse 8, all of them will wear out like a garment.
The moth will eat them up.
Verse 9.
So on Palm Sunday, you've got the adulation of the crowd.
On Good Friday, you have the abuse of the crowd.
And, of course, to some degree, this may have been two different crowds.
In other words, you kind of have Christ's friends there on Palm Sunday.
And then largely kind of his enemies there on Good Friday.
But I think that might kind of hide a more disturbing insight,
which is that it's likely there was crossover.
In other words, I think Jesus' friends, it was a very small group of people.
Probably not enough for a crowd.
And in the same way, those who were really dead set against him, again,
it was a pretty small group of people.
Probably not enough for a crowd.
So, in other words, it kind of begs the question, who were the others?
You know what I mean?
Who were these people kind of just joining in with whatever's going on?
And I think it's kind of a thought exercise to reflect,
to what degree was it like this crossover?
It's like people at both events.
I mean, it's a kind of disturbing thing.
Now, you might ask, are you sure?
How could you be?
And, of course, I'm speculating on this.
But it doesn't seem shocking or surprising to me at all.
Because I've seen crowds.
You probably have seen crowds, too.
Especially when crowds start becoming mobs.
That's like, there's like a weird dynamic kind of going on.
I mean, crowds are kind of fascinating, fickle, disturbing things, phenomena.
In his book, Confessions, St. Augustine describes how a Christian friend of his named Olypius
had sworn off gladiatorial events, like attending these.
It's kind of weird to think in Christian history at one time that was like a thing.
Someone's like, I've got to quit those gladiatorial events.
I can't go to those anymore.
It's too violent.
And this is like a struggle.
And he promises himself he's not going to go.
But there was this group of friends.
And they were like, come on, man.
You've got to go to the games.
And he like, for a while, kind of put them off.
Like, no, no, I'm not doing that anymore.
And then finally, they kind of wore him down, wore Olypius down.
And he agreed to go.
But he said kind of with the kind of boundary that he would keep his eyes closed.
And so he goes to the event.
And it works.
For a little while, until the first man is killed.
And the crowd just erupts.
And Olypius told Augustine his eyes popped open.
And he saw the blood there on the ground.
And it just like took him over.
He said, by the end of the event, I was cheering as loud or louder than all of my friends.
Like he just got swept up in the emotion, the power of the crowd.
Right?
That's the thing.
It's like, it's this emotional kind of intoxicating, powerful, and rather dangerous thing.
Now, does this mean crowds are like always bad or like always evil and stupid or whatever?
Maybe.
But I would say, I mean, I do think there can be, crowds can be powerful in a good way.
Like there can be something very beautiful about coming together for like, I don't know, the arts.
You know, for community and dancing and singing.
And I mean, even we go to like concerts and enjoy a band.
I mean, it feels good.
You know, doesn't it?
To kind of like lose yourself like for that moment.
Forget about yourself and your problems.
And just like kind of merge with the crowd.
You know, it's almost like you become like one organism or something.
Like it's a strange thing.
But we kind of, you know, love this.
And I think that can be beautiful.
And furthermore, there was actually a book written a while back.
And that was 2013, called The Wisdom of Crowds.
Anyone ever heard of this book?
By James Czerwicki.
And he outlines how large groups of people are actually often better at solving problems than like individual experts.
The example he gives of this is a famous thing.
It was like a sociology experiment where this guy named Galton, he did this ox weighing contest.
So he went to this state fair.
And he had people like guess like how much does this ox weigh?
And the experts kind of gave their estimates.
And then he kind of aggregated like thousands and thousands of individual votes of just people making their best guess.
And like weirdly, the median guess was like surprisingly accurate.
And where, of course, any one individual could just be like all over the place, you know.
But if you aggregate, again, thousands and thousands, it's like there's like a certain wisdom from, you know, kind of like lots and lots and lots of people.
And so Czerwicki goes on to outline certain conditions, though, that must be in place for crowds to retain or attain wisdom and kind of resist becoming mobs.
And this is some of the things he outlines.
Here's what has to be kind of kept.
Diversity of opinion.
Independence.
Decentralization.
And then aggregation.
In other words, what's key for a crowd to be wise is precisely that it not become a crowd in the sense we're talking about.
Right? With like Palm Sunday, Good Friday.
Like in essence, the crowd must never crowd together.
It must never be in one place at one time.
Because I mean, this is kind of actually the wisdom of voting.
But you like vote independently.
You know what I mean? Like that's the whole thing.
Everyone just kind of comes together and we just try to like, OK, we're all going to come to a consensus about who to vote.
You know, like, no, no, no.
This is going to be crazy and not wisdom.
So in essence, because what do you start to lose when everyone comes together?
Well, you start to lose these elements, right?
You lose the element of the individual.
You lose diversity of opinion.
You lose independence and decentralization and then aggregation.
Instead, you get this kind of herding instinct taking over.
What do I mean by herding instinct?
I mean, imitating one another.
Anyone ever seen this in a crowd?
Suppressing personal beliefs.
You ever felt that in a crowd?
Just kind of like, I think I disagree, but I'm going to keep my mouth shut.
Deferring to the charismatic leader.
This is why the writer Soren Kierkegaard said this.
He said, the crowd is untruth.
The crowd is untruth.
Here's kind of the expanded quote where he unpacks this.
He says, there is a view of life which holds that where the crowd is, the truth is also.
In fact, that it is a need in the truth itself that it must have the crowd on its side.
There's another view of life which holds that wherever the crowd is, there is untruth.
So that for a moment to carry the matter out to its furthest conclusion,
even if every individual possessed the truth in private,
and yet if they came together into a crowd,
so that the crowd itself received any decisive, voting, noisy, audible importance,
untruth would at once be let in.
For the crowd is untruth.
In other words, even if you had all of these wise, measured individuals,
and they had the truth, but the minute you get them all together in a crowd,
it's like wisdom just starts flying out the windows.
You see, in a crowd, I dissolve.
In a crowd, I adopt the ideas, the opinions, the values of the group.
In a crowd, there is no me, only we.
In a crowd, I'm absolved of whatever is done.
For I don't consciously do anything.
We do it.
In short, the crowd is a mass of people where individuality is kind of dampened,
it's minimized, or even erased.
To return to Isaiah 50, I'm struck that as Isaiah kind of imagines what Christ will go through,
he sees Christ asking for a courtroom.
Did you catch that?
In verse 8, it says,
In the earlier verses, he's being mocked, he's being spit upon, insulted,
but these are all actions of, again, people hiding in a mob.
But notice, right, he's asking for a courtroom.
He's asking for a courtroom.
Why?
Well, the courtroom is the realm of the individual, right?
A witness must take the stand.
Not the mob, right?
No, the witness must take the stand alone and say,
This is the truth.
And even swear, like, this is the truth.
That's a very individualistic kind of thing.
They're forced to stand behind their word, not hide in the crowd.
In fact, in Kierkegaard's essay where this quote is lifted, he brings up this exact point.
He says, you know, no individual would, like, ever have had, under any circumstance,
they never would have had the nerve to walk up to Christ and alone, without any other support, spit in his face.
He's like, this would be unthinkable.
No one would have had the nerve for this.
Then he continues and says this,
But since they remain in a crowd, they have the courage for it.
What a frightening untruth.
So how might this apply in our own day, our own time?
Well, I think many of you are probably way ahead of me on this,
but one thing that I have hit on in past messages I will continue to hit on, as long as it is relevant,
which I suspect, unfortunately, it will be for quite a while,
is the turn, I would call it the dark turn, towards Christian nationalism in this country.
And specifically, really, in certain political and religious circles in the United States.
And sometimes I post about this online and I'll get pushed back.
People, they're just confused.
They're like, you're a pastor.
You're a pastor.
You're a Christian.
You don't want other people to be Christians, too.
I mean, don't you want there to be a certain cultural pressure to identify as Christian?
A little pressure to attend church?
That would be good for business.
Don't you want a kind of marriage in people's minds where to be American is to be Christian?
Wouldn't that be powerful?
They almost become one and the same thing.
Just think of what could happen if being Christian was the popular thing to be and do.
Just imagine if we could get the crowd to think that being Christian is great.
My goodness.
Would not revival just sweep the land?
No.
You know why?
Because a life with God, really a decision about who you're going to be with God, man,
that is a deeply personal and even individual journey.
The crowd cannot make a decision for or against Christ.
Just think of that.
The crowd can't make that decision.
There never was, never will be a so-called Christian nation.
I mean, certainly not a self-proclaimed one.
Because, you see, that's a crowd searching for an identity.
But crowds by nature immediately fall into untruth.
Which is why the so-called Christianity on display by those advocating for a more Christian America,
it looks a lot more American than Christian.
By the way, this is also why probably I think the optimal church size is smaller.
Because the more, the bigger and bigger and bigger you get,
I just think it's, you're just like, your chances for sliding into what the crowd will go along with,
you know, it just starts skewing.
And it becomes more and more tempting.
You know, and there is something powerful about a community,
but the beauty of a community is that the individual is still retained.
You know, people actually know each other.
You know, furthermore though, on this topic, I think many of us are somewhat shocked, confused,
by the people, you know, people we love.
Parents, grandparents, former, you know, or even current, like church friends,
or folks, you know, who taught you Sunday school.
You know, how could they kind of align themselves with this movement?
We get frustrated, we're shocked, we're surprised, dismayed,
cannot for the life of us understand, you know, how it could be.
And in fact, I've seen a social post that often, or various social posts on this same theme,
where they'll say something like, you know, how is it that, you know, my Sunday school teacher,
the very people, in essence, who taught me to like, you know, love my enemies,
are now like, open for the mistreatment of legal and illegal immigrants.
You know, it's like, it's just, it's anything but merciful, it's anything but Christ-like,
anything but Christian, like, you know, have they lost their minds?
You know, and I would say, you know, in the sense, I don't mean this to be snarky,
I mean it in the sense we've been talking about.
Yes. Yes. Yeah, I have.
I mean, remember, the crowd is a mass of people where individuality is minimized or even erased, right?
And that's the thing, you know what?
Deep down somewhere, part of them might even disagree.
You know, they might even think, the movement is getting a little out of hand.
You know, the crowd's going too far.
But the nature of the crowd is to suppress internal dissent.
And it takes unbelievable moral courage to stand up and say to the crowd, no.
No.
Now, am I kind of casting myself as the hero here, you know, the one willing to stand up to the crowd?
I don't think so, because I'm, well, I'm just not a part of that crowd anymore.
I don't know, depending on the story, I got kicked out or I left, you know?
And, you know, admittedly, it's fairly easy for me to stand up and say these things, you know what I mean?
Like, yeah, so I don't think this takes unbelievable moral courage.
But I will say, though, it's much harder for an insider in that crowd to make the break and to say, no.
No more.
So, yeah, this is kind of the dark thing.
Yeah, they have lost their minds, so to speak.
But, again, not in a snarky way, not in a shaming way, not because they're, like, bad people, you know?
No.
You know what?
Because they're people.
People.
And here's where I can just, like, kind of own it, too.
I'm all down with a good mass movement.
You know what I mean?
Like, there's something in me.
I'm like, yeah!
Like, I just have a different crowd.
You know what I mean?
I'm like, yeah!
Like, we're all kind of drawn and beckoned and tempted by such things.
You know, we all love a good crowd, you know?
But, ah, that's where I think Cherokee Guard's warning, Isaiah's warning is really good.
Oh, that crowd.
Almost always untruth.
So do we all just get to pat ourselves on the back now?
You know, good thing we're not part of that crowd.
As I've already hinted at.
No, no.
I think the invitation for us, in light of the cross, is to ask ourselves certain questions.
A, where have I or where am I slipping into untruth because of the influence of the crowd?
You know what I mean?
A little bit like, the crowd's everywhere, right?
The crowd's there at work.
The crowd's on the news.
The crowd's online.
The crowd's influencing you and I in ways that we can scarcely imagine.
Everything from, like, how we dress to how we spend our money.
Maybe to help kind of get at this from another angle, you might reflect on this question.
Where in my life am I most afraid of standing out or being different?
Rest assured, often a fear of the crowd's kind of underneath that.
B, realize that the crowd can never give you answers to your deepest questions.
What are the deepest questions?
Questions like, what does a commitment to authenticity look like in my life?
What does my commitment to follow Christ ask of me in this season?
What is right and what is wrong?
What around me is unjust?
Where is my own crowd lost in untruth?
You say, well, those are hard questions.
Yes.
Yes, of course, they're hard.
That's why no one asks them.
Or, if they're asked, who do they look to for the answers?
The crowd.
Ah, but here on Passion Sunday, we gotta turn away.
We must turn off the phone, turn off the news, turn away from the crowd, at least for a while.
Turn within, which is to say, turn to Christ.
And perhaps there, find the answers we so desperately need.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit, amen.
So on the night before his death, Jesus took bread.
He gave thanks.
He broke it.
And he said, this is my body given for you.
After supper, he took the cup.
And he said, this is my blood poured out for you.
Whenever you share this, remember me.
And so tonight, we together proclaim the mystery of faith.
Christ has died.
Christ has risen.
And Christ will come again.
So the way we'll go about taking communion tonight is we'll just go row by row, starting here at the front, and forming one line in the middle.
So when one row's kind of done or almost finished, then the next one can jump in.
We practice what's called an open table.
So if you're here tonight and you'd like to participate, then you're free to do that, regardless of your denomination or exact theology or whatever.
As I'll say in just a moment, this is the Lord's table.
It's not up to us to police the Lord's table.
So if something in you wants to connect with Christ, then you're welcome to do that.
Just know the red is wine.
The white is grape juice.
And finally, you can just partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to partake immediately.
Some like to come and kneel.
Some return to their seats.
But no one will lead you through the exact moment of partaking.
So this is the table, not of the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love him and for those who want to love him more.
So come.
Come, you who have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow and you who feel like you've failed.
Come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites you.
And it's his will that those who want to meet him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
Would you guys stand with us as we close with this last song.
On which the Prince of Glory died.
My richest gain I count but loss.
And poor contempt on all my pride.
See from his head, his hands, his feet.
Sorrow and love flow mingled down.
Did e'er such love and sorrow meet.
O'er thorns composed so rich a crown.
O wonderful cross.
O the wonderful cross.
Bids me come and die and find that I may truly live.
All who gather here by grace drawn near.
And bless your name.
Were the whole realm of nature mine.
That were an offering far too small.
Love so amazing, so divine.
Demands my soul, my life, my all.
O the wonderful cross.
Bids me come and die and find that I may truly live.
All who gather here by grace drawn near.
And bless your name.
Again, thank you all for being here with us.
If you're interested in a small group or attending a table event, supporting the table financially,
or if you're new and you would be willing to fill out a visitor card, we have a record of your visit.
You can take any of these steps by scanning this beautiful QR code above you.
Or if you'd like, you can fill out a physical card over here by the doors that you enter through.
And put them in this small little box.
Here are some other announcements for you.
Stuffed Easter eggs.
So during our Easter service that's going to happen in six days, on Saturday,
we're having an Easter egg hunt for all of the kiddos.
And if you hadn't had a chance to donate any stuffed eggs, then we'd like for you to donate some dollars to Maggie Tilford.
You can Venmo or Zeldos or anything if you have her phone number.
Or reach out to someone in the kids ministry and they'll be able to help you.
Now Holy Week started today with Palm Sunday and it continues on Good Friday.
And as Brett mentioned, we'll be attending Sachse's First here, Good Friday services at 7 p.m.
That's on April the 3rd.
It's called a cantata.
So it will be mostly music centered on the cross and Jesus.
Alright, special announcement.
Easter, because we rent space from Sachse First, will be celebrated on Saturday.
So please join us on Saturday, April the 4th, for our Easter service.
And there will also be a meal.
So the service begins at 5.
We'll be catering food and doing an egg hunt for our kiddos.
So come celebrate with us.
And there will be no service on April the 5th since we'll be celebrating it on Saturday.
Alright.
Now I'd like to send you into your week with this blessing.
So you can hold your hands in a posture to receive.
Or you can just open up your hearts to these words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day.
And it's especially true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with its yet to be determined highs and lows and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you are loved.
That you are worthy.
And that you are accepted just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to extend these same gifts of grace and unconditional love to everyone that you come in contact with.
Be blessed and we'll see you this coming Friday and Saturday.